jack is in Jacksonville Florida welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show sir
what's going on man I've done better
than I deserve how can I help
alright so I'm trying to get started on
the baby step process and I can't get my
wife on board she's 100% dedicated to
buying a home and over the past I'd say
two years or so we've been saving to do
it and we've gotten up to about 11,000
liquid and I see driving me nuts being
in debt so the other day I'd say
probably about a month ago I did a
google search on how to get out of debt
and your name popped up and I've been on
the train ever since and I've been
trying to convince her that it's the
right thing to do and it's just the
hardest thing in the world and I just I
don't know I'm stuck how old are you -
I'm about twenty eight there's how long
you been married almost a year we've
been together about six years and we've
been married for one year what'd she do
about what'd she do for a living what
did she do he works for Merrill Lynch
okay
that's the problem yeah so she feels
like she's got some expertise in this
area would you agree I don't know in
case he's listening I don't want to
sound like the bad guy you know I mean
no I'm not saying I wasn't making fun of
her I'm saying she's she knows she has
some pretty strong opinions about money
already before you ever came along or I
ever came along and I mean with what she
does for a living I mean what does she
do at Merrill Lynch I don't really know
we don't we don't really discuss work
she is she advisors are going to keep
that part out of our relations is she a
financial advisor no she's not a
financial advisor it's more to do with
like people's retirements and stuff like
that I mean but not she doesn't advise
people she she's a manager over there
okay all right well I think what you got
to be real careful
is to talk about why it is that you feel
the way you feel you're alright you're
allowed to have an opinion certainly
she's allowed to have an opinion okay
right instead of going in and going hey
I heard this crazy guy on the radio i
google-searched him and immediately she
goes no it's a scam it's a scam off the
internet man that's what went there
absolutely pyramid scam that's what what
they were had you know and if she didn't
say it that's probably what she was
thinking it's what I would have thought
if you'd come said that to me so I I
think what you got to do is you have to
walk through the ideas and walk through
why it is that debt bothers you yeah and
this is a big deal to me honey and I
really want us to be on the same page
about money because the number one cause
of divorce in America today is money
fights money problem the number one
thing people fight about in marriage is
money and money fights and this guy
actually has a proven system where
people don't fight anymore about money
yeah and I think we can get on the same
page here let's at least both of us look
through this information you give it a
fair look and if you want to argue some
points on it that's fine and I'll be
happy to listen to that but you have to
be happy to listen to me about my
opinions on this too because I'm half of
this train I'm half of this equation and
so you know we're not trying to take her
vote away from her we're not trying take
your vote away from you right now but we
do need to get on the same page on how
we're gonna do this stuff so right I
mean that that's like the second step of
step zero yeah getting on the same page
yes so but if you start talking about
all the things you need to do rather
than why you need to do them her shields
are gonna be set in concrete she's gonna
put up shields and hold them in concrete
and no one would blame her but if you go
listen I really think the right way to
buy a house and do it where the house is
a blessing instead of a curse is that we
didn't have any payments we had an
emergency fund and I can see how we can
get there would you please sit down with
me with an open mind and look at this
and don't cross your arms and stick your
lip out let's sit down and talk
this and let's look through this and
talk about how we can build wealth and
how we can work together on really one
of life's most difficult subjects and if
you can't have that conversation in your
house then you've got marriage issues
you don't have financial issues right if
if you if she comes to you with anything
and says hey I really want us to talk
through this and you go no I've already
made up my mind you know well that's
that's not how you're married it's not a
proper way to be related right ups and
so but I don't think that's what she's
saying I think what she's saying is you
you found some scam artists on the
internet and then you came in and told
her you had to sell her car this kind of
stuff and instead of talking about why
you were talking about what so don't
talk about you're absolutely right and I
think I think what it is is I just I see
how it works yeah I've done the math it
makes total sense it does and I'm so I'm
so convinced
yep that I feel like she should be so
convinced and she doesn't have the same
information you've got right that's an
unfair request and what happened with
you was you were already concerned about
why and then you found of what she
wasn't even concerned about why and you
brought her or what yeah this is what
we're gonna do I introduced her with all
the numbers and yeah you need to
apologize you screwed up yeah if you're
wrong and in this case you were I mean
you went out this wrong you went at it
like a guy who's been married a whole
year so hold on I'm gonna send you a
copy the book the Total Money Makeover
and the two of you flip through that
together maybe if you can just get her
to read that and just say listen I
screwed up but I am still excited about
these ideas and I really want us to have
an intelligent good quality marriage
conversation about these ideas
and if we don't do them after we talk it
all through I'll accept that but because
you have a vote and I have a vote but I
really I want you to care enough about
my opinion to look at this with me and
then I think that'll work maybe after
you apologize so hold on Kelly I'll pick
up we'll get you a copy of the book